vous êtes le chef d'orchestre d'une
fiscalité punitive
à défaut de dérouler la partition d'une
écologie positive unique clés d'une
transition énergétique harmonieuse
capable d'emporter l'adhésion des
français
cette politique confiscatoire et le
point d'orgue de ce que vous essayez de
vendre au français comme étant la
symphonie du nouveau monde
alors je vous le demande monsieur le
ministre quelles nouvelles orientations
décisives et stratégiques
proposez vous pour être à la hauteur des
enjeux de la transition écologique que
l'urgence climatique exige nous assumons
la convergence fiscale essence diesel
car en effet il faut libérer les
français et de la consommation de
pétrole en général et du diesel en
particulier et nous avons obtenu des
résultats et je ne les revendique pas
pour moi même c'est une action continue
aujourd'hui les voitures neuves le
diesel ne représente plus que 36%
ça ce sont des actions concrètes et nous
amplifions les choses avec la prime à la
conversion et elle ne rate pas sa cible
puisque 70 % des automobilistes qui
changent de voiture avec cette prime
sont des ménages non imposables et 80%
des véhicules soumis à la glace grâce à
sept crimes sont des véhicules diesel
donc oui il faut agir ici maintenant et
avec constance
je veux souligner monsieur le ministre
l'incohérence finalement de votre
politique de taxation énergétique fait
de volte/face permanent je vais précis
en 2019 moins de 20% des prélèvements
faits sur les carburants seront
consacrés à des actions écologiques et
environnementales et pour la seule
hausse des taxes pour 2019
non seulement vous mettez pas un euro de
plus mais les dépenses consacrées baisse
de 400 millions d'euros autrement dit
vous prenez plus aux français et vous
donner moins à la transition écologique
aujourd'hui mais nos policiers attendent
des réponses concrètes il en va de leur
sécurité et de celle de nos concitoyens
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple dans votre plan d'action quels
moyens comptez-vous donner aux forces de
sécurité intérieure pour stopper ce
climat de violence qui s'accentue de
jour en jour
en deux ans le budget du ministère de
l'intérieur aura augmenté de plus de 1
milliard dans quelques jours je viendrai
devant vous présenter un budget qui
augmente de 3 5%
est-ce que ça suffit pour régler tous
les problèmes la réponse est non mais
nous en sommes convaincus mais c'est
déjà une augmentation de 3 5% c'est une
augmentation de 575 millions d'euros
et je sais que j'aurai votre soutien
n'ont pas forcément sur toutes les
politiques mais sur la volonté de
réarmer de réarmer nos forces de
sécurité parce que c'est nécessaire par
un plan d'action majeure dans
l'immobilier par un plan d'action
majeure dans le recrutement et dans
l'équipement de nos forces de l'ordre de
1500 personnes seront recrutées l'année
prochaine et nous allons ouvrir rien que
pour la police près de 4500 postes dans
nos écoles de formation parce qu'il faut
bien évidemment remplacé aussi les
départs à la retraite et nous le ferons
nous avons poussé au maximum les
capacités de notre formation pour garder
un système suffisamment sélectif et nous
aurons les moyens de faire cela et 2500
postes seront ouverts en plus des 2000
postes ouverts cette année
et cet effort sera poursuivi l'année
suivante parce que sur le quinquennat
nous voulons recruter dix mille
policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires
et très vite et l'effort a été porté sur
les premières années les dernières
années il n'y aura besoin de plus que de
recruter 1500 personnes par an parce que
justement l'effort est porté
immédiatement mais il nous faut aussi
travailler sur la question de
l'équipement et sur la défense et je
vais vous dire que nous devons nous
retrouver sur la revendication sur
l'exigence que jamais aucun incident
aucune mise en cause d'aucune violence
contre nos forces de sécurité gendarmes
policiers pompiers ne soient acceptables
dans ce pays et je sais pouvoir compter
sur vous vous ai écoutés mais n'oubliez
pas d'entendre votre prédécesseur qui
disait aujourd'hui les français sont
côte à côte
demain ils seront face à face ne se met
pas la faiblesse vous récolterez la
violence
[Musique]